is it scary on the streets what is the
question you wish people ask you my
name's Dave hello my name is Olivia a
few years ago I was homeless for a few
months there are all sorts of questions
floating around the internet so let's
clear the air how do homeless people
become homeless
funny issues and you hear about people
you're losing their accommodation
I was made redundant for my Kara's job
where my pay was frozen so when you have
a mortgage council tax all the utilities
travel and food on your own everybody
just hold on where to homes people sweet
I still sleep outside of church during
the day off what quiet bar there can be
quite leimia you go do you get some safe
havens they sleep in doorways anywhere
what's undercover on a bus park bench in
McDonald's in a library if you want
safety is it scary on the streets
yes yeah I would say it's scary on the
streets because especially then was
around the corner I did have something
trying over me I was hoping it water at
the time I've heard it's their homes
people getting spat on or kicked that's
why I say to any homes persons do not
sleep outside a pub because obviously
people coming out who drunk
sadly I personally found a person that
deceased a bus stop 10 homeless people
get jobs obviously you need a bank
account and when you get a job even when
to be paid no ID no god I've heard about
one or two companies they do give a
chance to a homeless person and but it's
very rare
why do homeless people have dogs
companionship the loyalty that the dog
will bring they will not turn on them or
betray them or run off with their last
wife now note what is the question you
wish people ask me I hope you feel ok
just asking about that for me your
well-being or what can I do to help you
how can you help
[Music]
thanks for watching don't forget to
subscribe and click the bail to receive
notifications for new videos see you
again soon